special best gameplay on the board those
times Checkmate brilliant see on the
board Buddha is crashing ah this is nice
yeah
yeah you know I mean I know chess
players you haven't someone in a moment
when you can play beautiful and then
looks aside it means that yeah he's just
trying to make sure that yeah everything
is fine because when you focus on their
skin you can miss something but when you
look aside and then you are thinking in
a distance little bit then you
understand everything perfectly
but it's also such a beautiful
combination it's a rook sacrifice and a
queen sacrifice for the made to follow
and not immediately yeah and look at
this The Duda is going up and down in
his chair he's enjoying the momentum I
mean he knows he has calculated all the
way and Anish has to go for King H6 we
have to see that beautiful amazing
you know it might get into the best game
collection of the of the event and the
the public will have the chance to vote
or already can start voting on on the
official page of the tour King H6 on the
board Knight G4 check
yeah this is nice
look at this dude I smiling he just
can't hide his his Joy everything of
course
King G5 Queen F5 check
yeah King G4 runs into HD checkmate
what a beauty
giving a checkmate with a pawn
look at five so King G6 is the only way
and even King G6 gets beautifully
checkmated so it's not a spoiler If he
if Black Goes King G6
now he will probably go King G6 and then
yeah this rookie five rookie seven it's
it's a remarkably nice variation I'm so
proud of this one yeah beautiful I mean
you you spot it instantly and uh okay
this one needed some calculation have
you you can't uh call it out without
calculating but you you can't create it
for 20 seconds or 15 seconds and
you you have forcing everything Bravo
it is also a very nice Checkmate that we
didn't show yet yeah if after Rook G7
King G7 F6 is black goes
um
King could you go back there for a
second yeah just because okay then I
yeah
please don't resign I understand it's uh
no of course Anish designs he knows
exactly so we're gonna show one more
time King F7 runs into rookie seven
check King G8 and Knight H6 check the
bishop on B1
is there King gachit Luke H7 Checkmate
what a fantastic win by doodle and uh by
this he wins
the match against